this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
what a beautiful afternoon you can see
here we have got the brewer the beast
just at the background there who are now
going to drink and apart from the world
beast some other animals big armors I
can see them approaching from far good
afternoon and welcome to the beginning
of the game drive we have long been
waiting for
I am Sydney former Ally Miko see and I'm
travelling with Craig who is my camera
operator this afternoon I am going to be
looking for the interesting animals
specifically the case but when coming
across the big ones such as the
elephants and other big animals we are
going to stop and have a discussion for
incase if you want be part of our
discussion you can follow us on Twitter
hashtag Sephora live you can also follow
us on YouTube chat stream
so I'm going to see if we can have a
better sighting on this ahead of a
wildebeest and I can see this one big
elephant as well approaching from the
other side also baboons are here I can
see baboons as well here shelf o'clock
right in front of us
it looks like it's an amazing sighting
there because there's a lot of world of
is just by the open space
so we are right at the vo Telepan they
is one of the Nano perennial dams here
where the beasts are enjoying themselves
you can see some of them are done
drinking they are just relaxed I am so
very much worried about the lack of dung
beetles in the area for a while I have
been looking for the dung beetles here
every day and I'm not winning I am not
too sure what is happening
maybe the dung beetles are now just
after the elephants and they are
concentrating where they still a
population of elephants as well as the
buffalos s they like to eat those
droppings a lot so you can see now I
have got the worldA beast this where the
bees if you look at them from a distance
you'll see they've got a lot of stripes
today we can clearly see that they blew
over the beasts they are indeed striped
fur the Beast you can see just by the
side of the head these stripes are very
much clear at the moment
which is where the name brindle nose is
coming from as brinnel is a term which
means the stripes so I'm not seeing any
of the Zebras around here I know the
word beasts are always associated with
the animals such as zebras due to their
poor eyesight as the Zebras has got good
eyesight and which is a good
relationship because when it comes
through the Predators they can easily
won each other when the beasts have got
good sense of smell and zebras they
don't have good sense of smell it means
both these two has got a mutualistic
relationship they are both getting
benefit from feeding together
so you can see this weld abyss there is
trying to sniff so one of them is right
in water here I don't know the reason
why this one is deep in water maybe is
trying to cool their body temperature
look at that
this one looks tired when the little one
was going down I thought maybe the
little ones wants to feed from the knees
like the warthogs so it's nice and the
beasts can migrate long distances I am
just not to show in terms of the
kilometers but let me give you something
which determines the low injectivity of
their movement these animals they can
migrate according to the availability of
food so if the food is nearby they are
going to obviously stop nearby but if
the food is far they are going to walk
long distances in other words the
migration the distances are determined
by the availability of food so this is
normal here by the Juma Game Reserve and
other areas as well well the beasts when
they are walking you will see the
normally walk and they keep changing
according to the availability of food
now let's go to Taylor who's got a
beautiful cage
the right to everybody hello good
afternoon thank you so much for joining
us today we have a special guest
appearance of Columbus Wilde and a named
scrap comes up no it doesn't off she
goes she's had a drink
this is a great start so let's tell
everybody who I am since aw what do you
think well Jack very quick introduction
hello everybody my name is head of Jay
mccurdy and on camera with me today
sense or did you get all of that right
we're going to follow
salamba the young daughter of Tandy I
wonder I wonder I wonder where she's off
to can I just tell you the quick joke
the joke is that I didn't know where I
was going and I was like okay fine we
were going to the mawashi because we
were fine Tambor and then I just turned
the corner and they took that not tumba
Columba the infla number was just there
so that's great so great start to the
afternoon and now she I think she's
using the luxury facility that looks
like a luxury facility faced from what I
can remember I can't hear any animal so
I was just I thought I heard something
in the distance like maybe a herd of
elephants but that's not the case at all
though she goes
just one lling down the road
Kristen thank you so much as your
hilarious he said finally I don't have
anything that's running away from me
no for for a change this morning if
watch the sunrise Safari it was a
disaster because I couldn't find any
animals I and I went up to puffles look
down because Jamie well she said to me
there's mating lipids here and she had a
great sighting of him I couldn't even
get that right then ran away from me
she's just walking past another mud
wallow now she didn't even care for the
dives did you see that she showed no
interest whatsoever let's go and see
where she goes trash boys this is going
to be fantastic
well I'm hoping that this is going to be
fantastic I was actually going to church
with Church where we were gonna go via
the Malati over those doves can I just
one moment you have to appreciate the
two doves that well I suppose they
survived didn't they'd had a near-death
encounter of a leopard and all they
wanted to do was just come down to have
a drink of water okay lovely showing all
you all the animals now while we have
them before they decide to run away from
me again slow numbers not going
particularly fast up the road you can't
see her now but she's kind of just
around the bend
she's actually moving very quickly I
don't know where she's off to you she's
got her ears pricked forward and she
seems to know exactly where she's going
hmm
is she going towards her koumori I don't
know we'll wait and see right Sydney
however has not got such a small animal
in front of him he's got a rather large
one and it's walking quite close by
the elephant has just arrived now and I
can see the baby is following while the
other side the worldA beasts are now
trying to move away from the dam as the
elephants are coming in
I think the worldA beasts are not very
comfortable with the presence of this
big animal here around them you can see
this elephant looks very much thirsty at
the moment is drinking and this kind of
animals can be able to drink 150 to 250
liters of water a day
that is quite a lot
so the Sun is getting hot at the moment
maybe after drinking they might display
display some of the mad wallowing
so you can see that these elephants are
really thirsty so it has been a very
long day the elephants can be able to
drink up to 18 hour they can be able to
feed up to 18 hours a day
so I can see that this is one of the
best sightings at the moment we divert a
boost nearby and all the other animals
so I don't think is fair if we don't
share this kind of spectacular sighting
with the other viewers
what a beautiful sighting and welcome to
the beginning of our very special
sighting I am Sydney a former on my cozy
and I'm coming to you live from the
western side of the greater Kruger
National Park here in South Africa sabi
sands Juma game reserve I'm just not far
away from the via Telepan he have got
this very beautiful sighting of the
elephants who are trying to have a drink
at the moment while the world beasts are
watching as the world beast got here
first it is amazing to see that the
little one instead of drinking water the
little ones needs some calcium she
doesn't want to drink water
she needs some milk I can see that she's
trying by all means to get hold of the
teeth so that she can get a milk me this
is a beautiful sighting elephants are
just beautiful just by looking at the
elephant's ears you can see you are
indeed in Africa the elephant's ears
resembles the map of Africa look at that
so the little ones must have to be
drinking milk a lot
you can hear that we don't only have the
elephants here and the world of beasts
we do have other animals the baboons are
also making some calls but those calls
are not winning course they're just
normal course I know baboons when it
comes to the Predators they always warn
other animals so the baby elephant is
going to be here until they are about 18
years is when they are going to be
chased away a jaded by looking at the
size of that baby I think the baby might
be going somewhere between two and three
years
remember the elephant's got two nests
these little ones until they're between
three and four and after that they will
be part of the very same head but when
they get a 16 to 18 years is when the
little ones are going to be independent
completely so here the mother has to
nest the little one and teach the little
ones all the manners elephants they have
to be feeding make use of the trunk and
in order to use the trunk while they are
still very young
they must have to go through a certain
training from the others to know how to
utilize the trunk so you can see on a
convoy the little one is leading so it
is not the responsibilities of the
little ones in order to leave the head
what we are seeing there is not normal
normally the head of elephants is headed
by a matriarch which is normally the
oldest female is the one who is
responsible of a decision-making as to
where we are going what time and we're
going to be back here and which
directions are we going to feed this
afternoon you can hear the baboons
so I'm left now here with the a
wildebeest and I can hear the baboons
making noise everywhere here around me
and these baboons noise is bringing us
to the end of the special broadcast of
special sighting I am going to carry on
now and look for more animals
so you can see that the where the beasts
were just giving the largest land mammal
a chance to come and drink now the Abegg
again right on their feet they are still
watching the legislature moving away
from this water hole
so this part here where this world a
beast
it is ideal because this way the bees
can be able to see far it's much more
open here with you and see there some
baboons here so now we are going to
Jamie it is also about to start by the
tent awesome it's something that I've
really missed since I've got back he's a
wonderful sighting of a Sydney nothing
of Sydney Oh her sighting of elephants
drinking I'm sorry something bit me on
the side of the nose as we read life
enough I've left eyes watering so happy
oh very good afternoon to you all my
name is Jamie the soft and hinge Andre
is on camera with me and the reason that
we are out in the tense force afternoon
is because we're having some tech
difficulties with the Mara and Chandra
needs to be relatively home-based
because he is quite an important man
when it comes to running things is
another important man in he's hiding
through the window he's hiding his idea
he's tried Roddy you must have known I
was gonna do that that of course is a
con Roddy he is our tech genius out here
now the most exciting thing about at
this afternoon's events of while for me
at least Chandra wasn't as excited as I
was because he's already seen this it's
a return of them upon EBS I was so happy
I really hope James knows about this
because I really feel like it will bring
him so much joy look at them they've got
an even bigger entrance tunnel to their
a skull and they've ever had before that
is incredibly disconcerting watching
myself ten seconds ago in the background
but
anyway nevertheless there are the Mopani
bees and they have returned in numbers
greater than ever before this is an
absolute joy to sit and watch as they
come streaming out of their little waxy
entrance tunnel or exit tunnel I suppose
it goes both ways sorry Jean drei left
in the way isn't this absolutely
beautiful so for the last I don't know
when did we first spot them upon EBS two
years or so ago I would say whenever we
set this tent up the Pawnee bees have
been a constant feature of our lives and
I was truly devastated when I saw the
entrance tunnel was broken and looks
deserted and devoid of life and it was
like that for a very long time Chandra
that is stunning what an absolutely
beautiful view now right now what
they're doing in their little hive is
creating what is said to be the sweetest
honey of all bees but to subscribe or
whether or not that is actually the case
we'd have to break open the giraffe
skull and destroy their hive in order to
get to it so I don't think that there's
something that we will ever ever do we
also we also know that the these
particular bees are attracted to sweat
so if by the end of the afternoon they
are buzzing all over us then you'll know
exactly why now I'm pretty certain I've
got your name wrong bug marker pad
marker bug maker I'm really sorry you
say Wow or something along those lines
I've forgotten once you said because
I've forgotten your name yep there we go
it is it is indeed pug mark I'm very
sorry I was absolutely I was right the
first time
pug marker says something about this
being absolutely amazing it really is
I'm probably going to have to move them
outside at least for the duration of our
segments in the tent which is quite sad
because I always worry about disturbing
them but if they've survived two years
of us coming and going in this tent I'm
pretty certain that they're going to be
absolutely fine
no princess Kimberly these are also
known as stingless bees
no they do not sting humans they can
guess a little bit much when they crowd
around your your face they obviously in
search of any kind of moisture so sweats
liquid around the eyes around the tear
ducts up your nose that gets a bit much
at times when they do that and what you
find is if you accidentally squash one
which I'm afraid to say does happen
because now you know you do that and all
of a sudden there's a squishy little map
on EB it actually attracts the rest of
them and they all swarm towards you so
that while they don't bite they can get
a little bit irritating which is why I
think I'm going probably to avoid that
accidental squashing of a map on EB I'm
going to move this outside for the
duration I of course have that option
available to me Sidney's out battling
the elements of course including the
Aparna beers
I am doing some tracking at the moment
as I want to say if we are going to find
some cats in this area or not but so far
there are no updates I'm heading towards
the area where Haku Mori was spotted
this morning and maybe our luck is on
that side so he around central is very
much quiet maybe Akuma is not down with
the occupy and he was seen having this
morning
I wonder how he managed to catch the
porcupine as
James there are no updates at all with
regards to attend Ghana and the new
girlfriend ting on has been introducing
a lot of girlfriends to ah see
unknown girlfriends he knows where to
find them so but so far there are no
updates with regards to his whereabouts
together with his girlfriend so our
saying
Okumura I don't know how he managed to
catch the porcupine as hunting a profile
can be a very serious mission I was once
on a sighting wear a leopard field to
catch a porcupine this bug mine was very
clever when the leopard was coming
epic open was reversing and the leopard
was going back and when the porcupine
goes forward leopard was following and
you will see the porcupine training
tearing his back and the leopard is
going back he tried to even crawl and he
tried all the different strategies but
you couldn't win that porcupine that day
so catching a porcupine can be a serious
mission and they can also be dangerous
sometimes because if they don't approach
the porcupine nationally they can end up
getting those quills on them and if
there's nobody to assist them they catch
big cats they can die from those pills
so it's a very serious protective arm Oh
the elephant has been here it looks like
it has been quite a lot of elephants so
here I am
the bush is changing I can see already
the grass is reaching the final stage of
development the grass only of climax
stage now they are starting to get dry
some of them so the Sun is too much so
when the grass is getting dry now by by
the beginning of March you can see that
when when me some of the PACU pines you
might find that they are old and when
getting old because of fighting and
encountering quite a lot of challenges
they lose the queers and you find that
they don't have a lot of queers anymore
what I have seen the leopard trying to
do that day is they they try by all
means and get an area which does not
have queers that is where they
capitalize to catch these porcupines if
not that they try to see if they can
have an opportunity to turn the occupy
and so that they can catch them so but
the leopard has to be very hungry to go
after the porcupine
I don't think a leopard which has got
quite a little food can get quite a lot
of motivation to go after the pack of
oil
so there's very fresh tracks of the
elephants here we might be lucky with
the elephants in this area
Paul the animals are so very much
unpredictable and I will give you a very
good example maybe this is something you
have here before not long time ago we
have witnessed a female leopard which
was killed by tenganan so Okubo and
Kalama the interaction they can be very
much unpredictable so if they meet the
chances of Okamura to take action
against Kalama they are also very much
hi so normally we see the females
fighting the same sex and we see the
males against the same sex but it is
very much rare to find that a male is
killing a female so that is why it's
important sometimes to consider the
behavior of animals we are seeing rather
than just focusing on the text books
because the text books sometimes they do
contradict what we are seeing here out
in the world so sometimes we talk about
what we are witnessing which is
completely different from what we are
reading on this different menus we are
studying most of the time so there is
quite a lot of things that are not yet
discovered on these animals and some of
these discoveries because we are sparing
much time with these animals we see
things which are totally unusual
so now let's go back to Tyler who is
trying to reallocate the shy Columba
hello everybody hello hello we're
searching Columbo went into the
Milwaukee which we then followed her for
a while and then she just went up a
steep Bank like this and jumped up on
top and came out somewhere here but now
I don't know where she's gone and I'm
trying to see if I can find tracks she's
making strange sounds I don't know what
she was doing if she heard somebody so
sorry I'm just got a very quickly focus
on the road just to see if I don't miss
any footprints
we'll go back down I mean I'm sure she's
going in the direction of twin Dan's
that watering hole itself yeah yeah we
need to turn around she's gone but where
did she go why did she come up here if
she's gone into some of these drainage
lands that's gonna be a disaster
we'll have to probably move on from her
and try to come back a little bit later
because it is super thick I mean even in
winter we struggle to drive along these
drainage lines is absolutely no ways
we'll be able to do it in summer okay so
now we need the squirrels the Franklin's
the spur files anybody else that wants
to shot Leopard we need them right now
see she could have just crushed janggun
down that side
so who sins on I just got a scan ring
Lee Rainie Rainie hard
wonderful seem deserve about gremlins or
any of this afternoon to know let that's
off you go to Sydney who's having some
more luck
apologies for the inconvenience is due
to some bad signals and the boss is
still very much thick
we are still here at the rainy season
the bush is excited and we cannot blame
the bush for that because this bush when
is looking nutritious and growing big is
benefits for quite a lot of animals so
now I am heading much more towards the
tree house them after three of them I'm
going to wear
Coco Marie was spotted I'm just hoping
is gonna come and drink there by the
tree Asda but I know next to the aina
dad is also some other water day where
you can also have a drink because
animals don't mind water from their port
horse
but here where I am I am not seeing any
tracks there is no much cat activity
since
Hana decided to leave us to go up to us
known Losey area is very quiet even
Kangana is not around so there's no much
leopard tracks here there used to be a
lot of leopard stress because these
animals they used to sometimes take each
other's kill like when was on of course
something Ching Ghana will come so which
means you will always see the tracks
around here everywhere because of that
so here I can pick up very very nice
push something very important here in
the bush is that the Rhino beetles I
haven't seen them feeding on the dance
because remember we have got different
kind of beetles so the Rhino beetles
I've never seen them handling the dance
like the dung beetles we are having but
if we look at the structure of the Rhino
beetle and look at the structure of the
dung beetle you will see that the
equipment's are not the same they the
dung beetles that are eating the dance
they've got a spade like they've got a
spade like Fran structure helps them to
dig and we ask them in order to collect
the droppings but the Rhino beetle you
can see with those two horns cannot have
in order to get the droppings the
particles from the droppings to
construct a ball so the Rhino beetles
are so very much beautiful they are
good-looking beetles but I I like the
the dung beetles
for now let's go back to a jami'a by the
tent I feel a little bit like an odd
Disney princess in a way with all these
Mopani bees around me I took the skull
outside and then felt so guilty that we
brought it back in again because all the
more Pawnee bees looked so lost and
distraught that we felt bad so we've put
it back where it was
so that they can come in and out so if
you see us surrounded by the Pawnee bees
that's why and I've just got to hope
that none of them land on me and I don't
you know forget and accidentally well
squash one we also have this this
tenters actually becomes something of an
ecosystem in its own way we have an
entire family of geckos as you know the
weather they call the end button spiders
made it a home at one point there we go
there's a striped skink one dragged
along at the top of the tent we've had
an Eastern tiger snake slithering around
at some point or another although it's
largely the geckos and the lizards and
the skinks that enjoy their time here
I'm sure there's a whole host of other
spiders that we haven't really noticed
but perhaps the most distressing is
what's happened underneath the tent a
couple of weeks ago we thought we'd had
quite a big rain and we thought that
perhaps the the floor of the tent had
washed away when we compacted it and put
it all back together again and the next
day it was uneven one small we realized
that there had to be another explanation
to this although Steph and I had
something of a disagreement about this
because he was convinced it was water I
was convinced otherwise anyway it turns
out that an entire family of rodents has
moved in underneath of the tent and as a
result we now have large holes in the
form of tunnels that move all the way
through the floor of the test meaning
that if jean dre falls over it's
probably not his fault at least in this
particular case it's because the chair
goes over backwards yeah exactly exactly
beautifully demonstrated Thank You Jon
Dre it is because there's a family of
rodents that persists in excavating
underneath our tent we haven't quite
figured out it
actually what it is we're going to do
about it but while we sort of
problem-solve and brainstorm that we see
amazing things on our live safaris we
see lions we see lepers we see elephants
drinking we see all sorts of birds but
the truth is what we really want to show
you and I know what you get really
excited about is grass now we try and
meter out the chests that we have about
grass because sometimes it gets so
overwhelmingly exciting that people
actually can't take it and sometimes we
get reports of or viewers fainting when
we overdo the grass segments but today
we're going to take that risk because
the dry season is approaching the
flowers of the of the flowers but the
breeding parts of the plants of a glass
the littler the breeding parts of the
grasses also known as the inflorescences
are in full bloom right now but they're
starting to dry out meaning that our
opportunity to tell you all about
grasses is relatively limited because
once they disappear then I have to tell
you there's not one among us who can
tell the difference between one species
of grass and another it is only at this
time of year so then I was thinking you
know when we have a whole host of
different grasses here what shall we do
with them how can we make this slightly
more exciting and I thought well I do
know that some of you would really love
the opportunity to demonstrate a note I
use the word demonstrate and not show
off just how much you've learnt from our
live safaris over the the number of
years that you've been watching some of
you actually astound us with your
knowledge and I often find myself
gobsmacked with my jaw hitting the floor
when you can answer some of the
questions that we put to you and find
out information that gives us an example
of your true abilities as researchers
sir oh yeah we're having a minor crisis
here it's falling apart
oops now I'm throwing a tortoise shell
across the room so here's that the idea
is every segment and we might do other
stuff as well never fear because I
wouldn't want any of you to get
overwhelmed by the power of grasses and
find yourselves too excited
nature girl says wait let her take her
heart polls before the start of this
grass segment maybe take two just in
case you never know all right we're
gonna do a lot of grasses so prepare
yourselves take a deep breath get
yourself a fan perhaps maybe have a cup
of tea nice and sweet with a plenty of
sugar sugar of course comes from a grass
we're gonna do a quiz on each and every
single segment that we do that is going
to make Emma's job extraordinarily
enjoyable and final control I think
she's in d2 so she's going to be sifting
through all of your answers first up is
the easiest of all of them I'm not going
to tell you what it is and I will only
tell you what each grass species is in
the next segment that I do how does that
sound so we're going to have a look at
at first you're going to see the
inflorescence and then I'm going to put
it under the microscope because I have a
microscope and as you know you cannot
let me loose with a microscope without
being forced to enjoy endless amounts of
discussion about just how extraordinary
in nature's oh oh Jamie's focus is
appalling there you go wow that's really
cool actually look at the spikes on that
all the winds gonna blow it out from
under there let me just put my finger on
it to hold it Jamie stop shaking it's
ridiculous too much sugar in your tea
there you go all right just stay okay
I'm not gonna touch it anymore because
I've got the got the shakes
joy in Hong Kong is already on it she's
already given the answer I'm going to
hold off remind you you've just seen
most of you using Twitter will have seen
joy in Hong Kong's answer or using
YouTube I think joy uses YouTube so you
would have seen her answer already ok so
I didn't think that through because I
was gonna say I'm not going to give the
answer until some more of you have had a
chance to think about it and perhaps
give it but let's go because joy has
absolutely spot-on told us what it is it
is our worst type of grass we hate this
grass ok and you've there you therefore
have to hate this grass as well this is
a carrot seed grass indeed and do you
think I can remember what the Latin name
is you think I would wouldn't you well
you would be mistaken besides I have a
rule when I present these live safaris I
have a rule that I don't break out a
Latin name unless I can tell you
something interesting about what the
Latin name means otherwise I think it
really is just pointless you're just
listening left names of people people
are never going to remember it and
you're only doing it to make yourself
look good James says that's his favorite
grass is it because it irritates us is
that is that purely out of badness you
it's your favourite grass because it's
the one that gives us the least joy you
see the thing is is you saw those spikes
on that seed now that of course is a
very very efficient method of seed
dispersal that is of course provided it
if it comes off again which when they
get stuck in our socks they don't yes
Monique exactly it ruins socks unless
you have the patience of an absolute
saint
if you walk through a patch of this and
it doesn't you know so just one little
piece sticking up out of the ground if
you walk through a patch of this you
will find yourself absolutely covered in
these grass seeds and they don't go
anywhere I suppose if you have hair if
you look at fur perhaps it's more
efficient because it doesn't stick quite
as seriously I'm gonna hate myself for
this I don't know there you go look
that's
it's also wet hmm no James this is not
your favorite grass seed you are
mistaken totally mistaken right while I
get that out of my hair let's go across
to Taylor who is much more sensible than
I am and probably doesn't have any grass
seeds in her hair
Jamie what on earth have you put in your
hair also everybody if you didn't notice
Jamie has taken over the role of
entertainer for the sub Thank You Jamie
I had to do it this morning but I'm so
thankful to be relieved of duty so now I
will be serious Safari Taylor I don't
know if my eyebrows moved I think my
cheeks just moved I don't know it'll
embarrass days ago away but tell me
where is it where's the leopard is she
there I'm coming for you tell amber I'm
gonna catch you now by the tail making
me drive around in circles and she's
probably just been sitting there the
whole time too so this cars gonna conk
out just now cuz it's gonna come out he
told you just pops out a full bath full
all the time she's in this tree she's
getting in big trouble
been driving around in circles
thank you very much that's my new name
stress come back come back I don't know
where she is go away but please say
again where the leopard was that you
were whining about I know she's gone
back in the Malati I don't know what do
you think Sansa there's a girl away bird
way she so she ran up yeah I just crazy
it's super steep don't get art because I
will just flush her art in the potato
and then she'll run away I don't want to
do that she knowing they'll say but she
could have run up and then run back down
fizzle back into the maratti yeah she's
making me work and we're not even
halfway through this firing it that bird
calling Nina is a woodland Kingfisher
Nina who's directing today said there
was nice ambient from that bird so I
thought I better tell you all and me
know what that bird actually is we're
going to hit a log now hold on please
Hey up we go was a small one I'm
dramatic in case you haven't noticed
casual reverts reverse a russki okay we
gotta go back into the mawashi again the
moon watching doesn't like us very much
but
stop making noises in the car sorry
everybody it's full bar for gear just
it's kind of has a mind of its own
I can't I don't think when it does that
it says very nice things to us in car
language Nora I'll have you know I can
be very serious very very serious thank
you very much you must stand up in my
vehicle you must call the animals go to
a lion then watch how serious I get then
when else can I be serious in a lion
hunt super serious Sally Taylor yeah
trying to think when I was I'm really
serious
when people mess with my food it'll win
Elsa my serious you can't even say
anything that's disappointing
I'm serious about I don't know I think
that's it
guess what other things I'm serious
about I'm serious about Payton dogs I
have a serious fear of sharks something
else that I don't ground about ever you
hear me joking about sharks not even
once so she was here this is yeah she's
now gone obviously she taped some
profile footprints
anyways if we go back to
I have got my favorite animals at the
moment some of them are underneath here
I can just see the movement of this
dance one is here you can see another
one is there oh yes the movement you can
see that they are busy now doing some
constructions so a lot of holes are
showing that a lot of balls has been
developed and has been taken away to the
burial site so this is amazing
insects they are busy doing their job
but apart from the insects I want to
tell you something today coming here by
the world life environment is very much
beneficial to our health these trees I
know a lot of people don't take trees
into consideration they only think about
game viewing and they think game viewing
is the only one which plays an important
part when it comes to their the relief
of the stress level so today I want to
share something with you coming to the
bush like this helps in order to boost
the immune system and it also helps in
order to lower the blood pressure again
those with surgeries can easily quickly
get recover what happens here is that
these trees that we are seeing here when
they are breathing they give off some of
the chemicals such as fight on sighs
they fight on sides are the chemicals
given by the trees in order to fight
diseases and to fight the insects
when we inhaled those fights on sighs
they then helped us because they do
boost our immune system via the blood
cells and they also give what is called
a natural killer this natural killer
kills what is called the affected
viruses so the viruses that are
affecting the body cells they get killed
by these natural killers so you can see
that when you are coming to the bush you
are going to get quite a lot of benefit
apart from game viewing you are going to
have quite a lot of health benefits so
now I want to remind you that the wild
earth expeditions they are now the
website is now open and the bookings
they are going to be up and
running as from the 17th of March so you
can come and gain some health benefits
here in the wide I am going to see if we
can find who come you know so I'm going
to be heading towards that area where
hookah Murray was ported oh look how the
dung beetles up is living just after I
left there the dung beetle is living you
can see there this dung beetle pushing
the ball
a child of the universe the Bears they
come and eat these dogs you know the
thing is the birds comes when there is
insects normally the elephant dunks when
they are getting dry they they the
material consisting the elephant dung
attract the termites and the termites
come in order to eat that fiber when
they come is when the birds will come
and disperse and open the elephant dung
so that they can get hold of the insects
in there so the best they get benefit
because the droppings attract insects
sometimes when they are fresh as well
you will see the guinea fowls coming and
dispersing even their own volition they
also go there and despairs to try and
get hold of the insects
so the way that is so very much a
perfect for the cast to move around at
the moment is slowly getting overcast
you can see that every day I don't work
I am just doing the forest bath so that
is why every day you can see that I am
always happy because I am in the wild
whereby I am gaining quite a lot of
health benefits and these what I'm doing
this job it is a forest bath job
so this area is the area where Haku
Marie was spotted so now let's go back
to Taylor oh is still a session
I am still searching I will be searching
I'm going to hurt all day yay so we
don't hate to children are given up on
Cleland but that's all the time it's all
of my time that she deserves because she
was rude and she just decided to put a
ton d on us she's really acting like a
mother right now it disappears on us all
the time but maybe we'll be lucky enough
to find her a little bit later that's
bad
sure I think we're gonna go towards
Chuck Dwyer s trip first just running
here so we're gonna head down that way
oh it was baboons I couldn't wake up
what was going on in the road there was
lots of tracks but the bubbles were here
they were playing about on the very
dangerously on Geary main but they're
pretty good not the same troop that
we've been seeing in and around camp
although they've left camp alone
touchwood thankfully
is that Wilbur see this is serious now
hey see we us check their check that
water just chilling in the mud now for
those of you who've been watching Safari
who are live for a long time you will
know that there's my favorite water in
the whole wide world and his name is
Wilbur and he lives at Jay Sebring pan
and he's missing half of his tail and
this looks like an old warthog - so the
only way we'll find out if this is will
but the warthog and if his legacy lives
on is if he stands up will the real slim
warthog please stand I was what that was
gonna work it wasn't there huh and the
oxpecker does not seem pleased but no
it's not will bites and pasta it's a new
Wilbur it's Warren it's not his brother
this water gear has pushed out will bear
this is Warren the warthog now I'm very
upset right now because this kind of
confirm said will be no longer lives
that Warren has now taken over Queens
old arrow this is very upsetting he's
not as impressive as Wilbur that makes
me really sad but this isn't nothing
that we get to spend some time with a
warthog so even though we don't really
like this fella we'll just watch him
waddle away you can come back it's fine
you can take this place
you've obviously fought him off you
wouldn't you deserve it me you know
watch in comparison to Wilbur this is a
small warthog this is a smallest male
water I've ever seen in my life but
that's just because I really liked
Wilbur a lot and we had we really close
relationship where he would do funny
things when I was around like slide
around in the mud or chase other warthog
balls away or get frisky with the
females you know he would do cool things
we had an understanding this
I wouldn't zero time for him African
pygmy water bug no wonder you've got no
ladies yeah because size does matter in
the animal kingdom everybody
maybe while dogs will be scattered out
on the edge triple what else
innovators and stuff
maybe she will be maybe she won't I hope
she is though
so we'll just check very Kathy she could
have moved she gonna move just slightly
she was going towards the mall to Anini
but then I believe she was back the
afternoon so I'm very pleased okay
sensors also on spotting duty sir please
we apologize if a camera veers off and
goes somewhere else that's because
you're trying to find you a late but if
I veer off for the road it's for the
same reason let's check
sometimes you have the game to refresh
your eyes
oh sorry everybody probably wouldn't
have got any of my jokes because the
gremlins were here and there attacked my
feed and then couldn't hear what I was
saying nor there probably weren't that
funny anyways okay we're coming up to a
favorite spots now any problem is is
there so many Marucci she could be in
any one of them I'm even gonna you know
what we're gonna first Garrett that's
all slowly we're gonna go yeah to make
sure we don't miss anything I saw kudu
very fired the bushes I'm just gonna
shout out all the things that I see
Lions it's a martial eagle and she would
stop and look at them don't panic I mean
ish isn't that big one that'd be great
but she's not okay so she's not in the
trees that she was in Brenda's its Enzo
what not yesterday morning day before
that
I hope she hasn't baked hated this area
it was nice seeing her every single day
she's not up in these trees hmm
David the weather is lovely today
there's a gentle breeze the sky is blue
the few little clouds which is providing
us with nice shade the temperature
that's not too hot but warm when you
start moving but as you go wouldn't blow
straight through your hair it's lovely
yeah is that everything you hope that
the way that was gonna be here
it's always nice at this time of year we
haven't had rain for a couple of days
which has been great
please go Chava can you come out nope no
could rather today at least we tried
there you can see I put an effort to try
and find the animals it's not very good
if I actually finding them we will go
this little bit further we're getting
gone the children driveway
then try
Oh wonderful
now I know Sydney city is still
searching I don't know if he's going to
hook her Maury but I know that
Rickson has located okay never mind I'm
not sending you anywhere cap got
canceled canceled axed
but you can tell Sydney that Ericsson
has located polka Maureen he doesn't
even need to search he's just gonna
respond and we're gonna turn in here
[Music]
we're still searching searching looking
for animals we'll see what's happening
at the dam maybe a little bit later I
heard stories about Shibuya down south
so we might see if we can't get a
long-range view of Cebu yeah I don't
know if a cub is with us we can't ask me
that but I maybe will be able to tell
you it a little bit later and she but
she wasn't on chat web but we will we
will try nothing okay well we're gonna
keep this bumble on a roll and off you
go to Jaime it's probably going to tell
you quite a bit about grass so what I'm
doing now is because I like to leave
things for the next generation of safari
life presenters that doesn't mean I'm
leaving it just means that I'm not going
to be in the tent to the next time we do
a ten segment so I'd like to leave my
mark for a couple of reasons one of
course is very educational and - hmm I
like to show that I actually went above
and beyond made an effort during my my
10 segments so I'm making a little chart
and it's going to be labeled as we go
through these grasses of course you know
it's going to happen by the time
somebody gets in here that was terribly
done you know how difficult it is to
actually get tape right when you being
watched this way so there we go I don't
have glitter with me unfortunately Nina
would like to know where my glitter is I
don't have glitter but I do feel that it
would add an extra sparkle to a grass
chart but as discussed prior to this
particular conversation there's only so
much excitement that people can actually
take and by adding glitter to grass I
actually think it might be a little bit
too much but I hope that you've had a
chance to get your heart rate back down
to normal
and now you are prepared for the next
exciting graph segment so as you've
noticed we I know you haven't noticed
because it's flown out from under the
microscope I have put another grass
under the microscope for you there you
go we'll start by looking at it oh my
word under the microscope come on Jamie
there we go it is an absolutely
beautiful grass when you look at it this
way and I must say them the microscope
adds a sort of dimension that it might
otherwise be lacking in our lives you
can really get grips to the contrast
will gets grips with the contrast and
colors work between the green and the
purple little hairlike projections
extending from the base of the grass
seed which I assume when ripe would do
the same thing that the carrot seed
hooks would do in terms of attaching
them to something perhaps even act for
wind dispersal but at the moment this
one's not ready yet when it comes to the
production of seeds because as you can
see they're grasses actually still got
flowers attached right at the base there
so it's still producing pollen and
allowing fertilization by pollen so you
can see the little brown bits are the
dead flowers and the little white bits
are the the live pollinating flowers
there you go of course very very
important to us mostly pollinated most
likely this plant by actually insects
maybe doesn't look like it's fertilized
by wind pollination maybe a little bit
by wind pollination I don't know so
there we go your next grass to answer
for me which grass is this it is about
the size of my palm in terms of the
length of the inflorescence the
inflorescence by the way when we talk
about the inflorescence we're talking
about the the part of the plant that is
involved in its breeding cycles and on
the leaf not the stalk just this bit and
that I find I'm no grass expert as you
may or may not have noticed but I found
that that's the most
identifiable flying adventures access
flying adventures something along those
lines has answered herringbone grass not
a bad guess but not what this is
interestingly enough I know I'm not
going to give you a hint at all I was
about to give away and give away the
game there I'm not going to know it is
not herringbone grass but a good guess
herringbone is one of the grasses that
we do see out regularly in Juma it is
actually I think one of the nicest names
for a grass the most descriptive Muldoon
is absolutely right foxtail or both will
brush what is the one I just just the
books got it as a different name I know
it is bottle brush cat cats cat tail
that's it bottle brush cat tail grass
the book has got it as cat cat tail
grass I know it is bottle brush grass
but that's what it is it's going to
multitude of different names now there
is a similarity here between these two
grasses
I really appreciate that Nina tried to
feed me the Latin name as described by
judy judy h of course is our resident
genius when it comes to such things and
in fact probably can comes to all things
but Judy H is actually endless I mean
entirely genuinely truly extraordinary
when it comes to powers of knowledge
memory and research without do th I feel
that a safari life might actually fall
so Judy a she's given us the Latin name
but Nina I'm not going to write it down
or say it until I've double-checked
myself because I fear I might make a
terrible fool so bottle bottle brush
cat's tail now earlier on while you were
with Taylor talking about her and I must
say I really did enjoy the way that I
really enjoyed the way the tailor said
Warren but I nearly had a deep-fryer
moment and that's a true in joke for
those of you that have been watching for
an extended period of time and really
nearly had a deep-fryer moment so while
you think about that course you cut
across to Sydney who definitely won't
know anything about deep fryers but
certainly knows a lot about searching
for lessons I have just arrived now here
we the kill is we've got him at the
moment and I saw the porcupine as well
up hanging by the tree you can see that
is the porcupine still having quite a
lot of kills I am very happy to see how
he is going to take down all those
queries from and they talk of it looks
like it was a very big porcupine
apologies I am NOT alone here by
deciding I do have some other vehicles
who I enjoying these
very spectacular unusual sighting
some very show the porcupine must be
completely different from the Warhawks I
just want to see how he's going to get
rid of those clothes because I know when
it comes to these other antelopes they
normally used the tongue in order to get
rid of the hairs but here what strategy
is he going to use I can't wait to see
that look at those very long kills how
is he going to take them off from that
beautiful porcupine yeah I can see that
the book where they are right on top
maybe he's just going to overturn the
occupier and feed from the stomach side
I don't think he has eaten a lot when
I'm looking at the bellies Rose indeed
this is one of those best sightings I am
also very happy to be here and I can't
wait to see how is he going to employ
his strategies in order to get rid of
those queers
so you can see the bellies are not
showing having a lot and maybe he has
been battling to get a lot to eat there
but it's normal this kind of animals
they've got a huge responsibility
because they hunt by themselves and they
get tired and they don't really like it
when is too harsh
look at those very beautiful
Janene the vendor name for the porcupine
is nu mu nu mu is the porcupine say is n
you and G you know
so they've reduced traditionally quite a
lot
apologies for the inconveniences here
where we are we have got quite a lot of
overgrown bushes which are causing some
of the network breakdown but here we are
still with hookah Hori
hookah Murray doesn't want to show his
face this afternoon is just leaping
there was a question if maybe the front
foot is a saw and I was just saying I
will wait until I see how is he going to
move sometimes limping after lying down
for long hours is normal when it comes
to the cats so I will just observe the
authority to see if there is any
problems
so now let's go back to teyla who is
having some antelopes I have just
counted a hundred and four impala and
that's not even all of them we're now at
the airstrip and the joy that I have
received is the gift of numbers and
there are plenty of them lots and lots
of impalas oh there we go
instead of having nothing this morning
I've been given lots of the same thing
which is fine so I'm gonna go ahead and
say probably about 150 in Pali here
there are so many and the rest of them
all at the top of the Astra but we'll
get to that group a little bit later and
they were all acting very suspiciously
when I first arrived on scene they were
all scaling down towards the tree line
in the distance and there's still a
couple of Impala there up on the termite
mound and they don't seem to be too
bothered right now none of them are
looking in a particular direction so I
don't know if maybe he's a hyena
pop-tarts and sort of just ran across
the road and then ducked into the bushes
or if there was a giraffe or maybe an
elephant that sort of caught the
attention who knows it could have even
been a day care little engine they
scared things and for a change unlike
yesterday afternoon the Flies are
bothering the Impala not as a sensor how
happy are you well maybe we'll still be
able to show Vincent or one of these
dead biting flies look like but it's
really awesome to see so many animals
gathering at this time of the year I
suppose when food is plenty there's no
real normal drama and its really seen
much fighting other than a bit of
jostling here and there but nothing too
serious
the youngsters actually sort of the year
old Impala fighting was one of one
another more than anything
look at these two grooming each other
Tim I mean I was dreaming that it was
wild dogs that would gonna come bursting
into the scene so I mean that would be
great however
who knows I don't know why I why I
however because I had nothing to really
say after that it would be really cool
whether that I suppose that I should
have a good chance of catching in a part
of it so many of them because they all
freaked out and sort of go into a frenzy
I would imagine and then some young
inexperienced and Pilar I think would
get left behind or sort of run the wrong
way I suppose having a lot of animals
are good because you've got a better
chance of spotting something accreditor
of sorts but at the evasion I don't know
and this is was you know 150 Buffalo
everyone's kind of at risk care oh well
it's lovely
okay we're gonna carry on now I want to
see how many and powder at the top of
the ashram to we'll be driving through
this herd
it's so nice I was hoping to have a big
herd of elephants here to be honest cuz
it's pretty at this time of the year
with a nice like that will come through
this afternoon ooh
wonder if there's going to be a bush
dinner I know it's not it's shawl and
his dog okay it chose me
oh there's actually not that emini apart
around here oh well maybe there's like
150 then it's like 20 off I don't think
I counted all of them correctly I think
I probably missed quite a few I didn't
count any of these on this side of the
termite melon that's for sure
the whole bunch yes Bo no they do seem
to be on alert that's why I mentioned it
that they were all staring at something
into the distance I don't know what it
was there but now they're fine there was
no snorting and we've been there for
ages way too now we're gonna have more
things maybe some in Yala in the mix
nope
Kosar are the most unusual the holidays
get into the get into a fight with a
baboon while I was in Zambia I told you
the story about the baboon grabbing hold
of the Impala and I think I showed you
your pictures I've got more oh no I
don't that's amazing macaque but I've
still got that yeah okay I don't know if
Ava showed you so I can pull some
pictures and maybe even a video from one
of my things now and so so that was
weird but then I had another experience
where I was sitting on the deck I was
just watching them parlor and the
baboons and water back and buffalo and
all the animals were eating there and a
tree pods and the next one at this
baboon his female baboon came out of a
beginner tree and she came down because
an elephant had come through and sort of
shook the tree and all the pods then
rain down I don't know why have my
sunglasses on my head everybody oh we
took if we're taking sins and I were
taking pictures with doing some selfies
trying to cool gangster and then I had
my sunglasses on my head because it made
the picture look better hey Tony - I
mean look it looks much looks much
better or such apparently Drive it's
cool Taylor and so anyways so this
female Boone comes down the tree and
then the next minute all the young and
Paula scatter they move off they're not
hanging around and this one Impala comes
through this you and she's just like I'm
gonna eat some of these pods I I deserve
some of these pods narcissus an elephant
his child doesn't mind all the other
animals coming around and feeding on
them and this baboon as she gets closer
grabbed her by her back leg and I was I
was like what and would not let go of
the back leg of the Sinhala anyway she
kicked and she whilst she got away in
the end but it was the and then that
baboon just took all the pods as many as
she couldn't she put them in front of
her and I was like wow so that was
pretty weird I mean I know though they
were desperate for food though I mean
there's literally nothing else for any
of the animals to really eat other than
the pods from the winter thorn tree or
Anna Anna Anna tree and it's on just
energy so yeah very very very hectic I
thought it was pretty hectic to kinda
see the competition how they were all
battling an odd right in front of my
deck in
ways I'm gonna scratch around here for
subbu yeah she's somewhere here we'll
keep an eye out Sydney's still got the
very sleepy book amore in the long grass
and you can see that now Hoku Mori is
lying down fled he was just up about few
minutes ago now again is up you can see
that the case can be unpredictable they
can just return us if they're lying down
that look at that when the cat is
yawning you must know that is trying to
also cool the brain temperature and that
helps in order to assist the animal with
the mental efficiency the Franklin's are
starting to make some calls let's wait
and see what who Kumar is thinking maybe
is gonna go up into the tree and carry
on feeding
so that occupying is not smelling bad
yet up there but I can see it has been
eaten quite a lot he already got
something he did manage to open some of
the queries from that occupy you can see
there this whole part which does not
have quails at all and see this even
some of the Flies they are just moving
everywhere and even some of the ants
so it's just looking at something maybe
he's irritated with the birds who were
just making noise but I can see that
he's thinking about something it's
difficult to read what is thinking about
to do let's just wait until he executes
his plan
shakin yeah you can see but when I'm
looking at his tongue can see the tongue
is clean it doesn't have any black day
showing that he has been using the
tongue to get those critters out I don't
know what strategy employed to get rid
of those crews so that's why I'm so very
much interested to see how is he going
to take more let's see now he's going up
look at that we are lucky he's going up
now oh it's not going anywhere
at least he's now doing some grooming so
this must be giving him problem because
the blood and everything attracts the
Flies
let's just see what he's thinking about
now Haku Mori
and see those whiskers that we are
seeing that they've a brassiere
if they lose them they grow back they
are very much important for their
survival because they use them as strong
sense organs but they got disorientated
for a while until they go back so let's
hope is not going to lie down again as
the tech that is something I can't wait
to see look at that at least he gave us
an opportunity to stand a little bit
unlike when it's just lying down flat at
least his is showing us something so it
must be difficult I can see he's injured
a little bit today I can see a injury
just by the front leg you can see
there's an injury there maybe there is
an injury which took place when he was
dealing with a porcupine
so it's getting clever because he's
laying down by that side because the
Flies are gonna come and bother him so
mean the PQ Pines I have seen occupiers
without the queers
so the occupiers I'm not too sure if
they can't really go back and they are
queers but I have seen this porcupine
we're losing the queries a lot you will
see them now becoming a vulnerable when
they don't have kills it means they are
vulnerable
so you can see that he's not interested
on feeding at the moment all is
interested to do is to sleep but this is
normal is not only hookah Maury all the
kids they are the same they prefer to
just like down for long hours
so you can see that now he is just on
his ass sleeping mode he is not very far
away from the waterhole as the treehouse
dam is just about a few meters maybe
after after this sleep he might go for a
drink
so but now let's go back to Taylor
right I'm also starting to get a bit
thirsty I'm gonna have to stop and have
a drink water myself but Haku Mori will
obviously be more enjoyable to watch she
choose between the two I'd probably
choose watching Holcomb where we have a
drink because we no luck with the impala
nor an awkward sea Boyer and I just
bumped into Callum from in coral and he
said that there's no tracks or anything
coming out he's been up and down several
hundred times and still nothing so that
says to me that seborrhea has not come
north or east she probably gone further
west or south so we shall carry on with
our game drive Dillon told me mrs.
Prince brother told me that there was a
giraffe with a baby I'd really like to
see the giraffe with the baby but he
said it was on that open area over here
by the edge trip but I couldn't see one
that's what I was really looking forward
to I wasn't gonna tell you until I found
that but now I can't find it so I
thought don't tell you okay we're gonna
go over the trip twitchit for dam wall
and we're gonna slowly start making our
way back to Jamaa and hopefully Columba
will be waiting for us at one dance
that's the plan
she's gonna be there and be stalking
impala maybe a big water back pool and
it's gonna be so dramatic they'll be
thunder lightning
not too much lightning there more
thunder big cards it'll be fantastic
we're going to set the scene what do you
think about that scene sins Oh like it
the Niraj also think so I say that sands
Oh agrees with me and then I Drive into
him into a tree whoops
there's lots of worn bells they
everywhere at the moment just notice
them around here around camp as well
lots of red and yellow hornbills we have
build hornbills so they're not actually
red or yellow just their Bulls are those
colors and now we're going past some
construction this is now camouflage
house child is painted and beautiful I
think it's because they're the type of
green yes khaki green that dark you know
like my shirt my dark khaki shirt it's
kind of like a cut it's invisible now no
one's gonna see the animals are gonna
walk straight in lovely right I'm gonna
hit up onto the trip to a dam and
hopefully there'll be some wonderful
creatures hanging around for us but if
you go to Jamie she's still in the tent
and she's still chatting about the grass
okay well good luck to Taylor I hope she
has some good fortune across on a
cheetah all the way that side all the
way across here in the middle of Juma
the baboons were alarm calling
frantically around the dam now this
morning I was out with my friend rusty
who of course has recently joined the
wild earth team and we stopped at
buffers of dam and we were there for a
good probably close on five minutes or
so economy-wide who you're talking about
I think we're talking about gorillas and
I was giving him a bit of history and
background there and then all of a
sudden there was the sound of leopards
mating in case you didn't get that from
my impression and there was ten Ghana
with the skittish female from both look
right in they were so close to the edge
of the dam but they were right at the
place where the drainage feeds into the
dam itself and with drainage line and
the grass was quite long and we
literally did not see two leopards and
we were sitting there for a good five
minutes so just goes to show how
difficult it is at this time of year to
find things like leopards you know what
makes it really difficult you guessed it
grass makes it more difficult to find
lipids so I hope you're ready for your
next is just making is it I bring this
up a fair amount due largely to the fact
that Andre said he
could not understand the guides interest
and excitement around grasses so we're
here to change Andres mind and perhaps a
few other minds around the world right
you all far too no favor for your own
good the winds blow my oh there it is
the winds blow my grass away okay you
yet right you're far too good at this
right get this one now wait hold on go
to the microscope yet Jamie's lost focus
it's blowing in the wind okay we're all
microscope anyway there we go fine guess
that one tell me what grass that is see
if you can figure that one out it's a
tricky one
it's got a very distinctive shape to the
little spiky twirly bits that probably
have a proper name definitely have a
little little proper name a proper name
but I couldn't for the life of you tell
you what they are because I learned that
so many years ago that I don't even
remember what I've forgotten what I
learnt about grass so there you go find
guess that one okay Chandra and I are
now done holding this incredibly in
tricky position that we've established
here there we go so now we're going to
slowly move and I'm going to move my
left on incredibly slowly because
otherwise I'm going to see in John Ray's
camera flying right let's see if you can
guess this one cross-eyed now looking at
the grass and look at the camera looking
grass camera grass camera crossmember oh
there you go
now this grass and the two grasses that
I showed you now mr. Anderson was known
as Lyons hairlines ear grass it is not
it is the second-worst grass in the
world after carrot seed grass and the
reason is is that at these little let me
see if I can get one there is a good
loose looking one might be a good one
let me try that one
I broke it listen I'm really struggling
with names today says wheat
somebody said wheat I'm sorry I don't
know can I'll get your name once know if
it is wheat it is not to eat although
wheat of course is probably one of our
most important grass species it is not
wheat it is not a grain plant and in
fact what it has in common with the
other two grasses would mean that it is
in fact almost the complete opposite of
wheat so here we go that's my my little
school project that I've got going on
here I mean this looks like something
that someone in third grade might have
made Berkeley and Edward peach is what I
got if you want to know if it is red
grass it isn't red grass is up there
with wheat in terms of a particular
value that it has to the world at large
or at least animals although we don't
really rely on red grass in terms of our
lives the animals actually really really
need red grass and here's the thing is
all of these grasses that I've collected
I haven't gone out of my way to collect
they've all been collected around the
tent well why don't you write the name
there would have been a giveaway and
there's something that connects carrot
seed cattail and this particular grass
whose name remains nameless until you
get it and that is that they are
something known as pioneer species I
make me write that pretty certain I can
spell pioneer
okay
pioneer grass you can think about what
that all means while you do off you go
across to our current Leopard pioneer
who's pioneered his way all the way into
the center of jummah over the last year
nevermind you're not going anywhere okay
pioneer species
so what pioneer species means is
essentially in an area like this like
outside our beloved tent it's an area
where the soil has been disturbed
through various reasons whether it's
foot traffic or in this particular case
probably because of the quite rocky soil
so quite a thin soil layer and a
drainage line just over there so
basically what's happened is loss of
water has gathered from the surrounding
areas including the open area of
quarantine and washed down and as a
consequence taken away a lot of the
nutrient-rich soils now pioneer grasses
specialize in this kind of environment
and that's why you always find these
species of grass along the roadside for
example that doesn't mean that they
can't occur elsewhere joy is a good
guess it's not a black jack jack is very
irritating we've got black Jack's
shouldn't really be around here too much
but we do occasionally see black Jack's
but it's not black jack something that
works in a very similar way though to
black jack so while you think about it
basically what happens is you are grass
that isn't in very good condition
grasses that capitalize on that and
don't need much in the way of nutrients
settle in and they tie down the soil
using the quite sort of shallow root
systems and they make use of what they
have they're tough
species as a result of them being there
over the course of time essentially what
happens is those root systems and the
plant itself actually holds the soil in
place and what that means is that okay I
want to keep you away for too long I'll
explain the whole process of grass
succession but apparently who Komori is
up in the tree he is feeding so we don't
want to miss that as he goes about his
spikey meal
we can see that now Okumura is trying to
open the stomach from the porcupine I
have seen how he is managing when it
comes to the removal of the quills his
even is grabbing all the quiz from his
mouth and throwing them on the ground he
just lost another big piece there and
that piece might invite the hyenas as I
saw a big piece just falling down and a
few minutes ago you can see it's going
down that to go and take what is just
lost look at that he doesn't know what
what what to do but I can see that he's
got the two minds look at him now coming
down he just lost a piece there you can
see things are coming out from the date
the porcupine
but he might pick up some of the pieces
and get them back again up into the tree
let's hope we doesn't feed in there as
it is not a nice place we can't see him
nicely but you can see that the stomach
is open the occupying is now excluding
things from the stomach I up there you
can see all the fluids are starting to
come down there you can see the things
coming from this time are coming out
look at that so those are the things
which are coming down at the moment from
the stomach
so I can see that here way is he's
trying to feed now on the pieces that
fell on the ground and you can see he's
even going down at the moment so he
doesn't want any of his competitor to
come here and get anything
so the hyenas are not here at all but
maybe because now the stomach is open
they might pick up the signal and come
to this port this is not very far away
from the hyena den the Jew Monday
they're just about three four minutes
away from here so we're just going to be
here until he goes back again high up
into the tree and carry on feeding I can
see that at the moment he's feeding on
the ground and it's not easy for us to
access him
so you can see that it was a big piece
which is on the ground there because
he's not even finishing and Z that is
just keep feeding the battling with
those quills you can see how it is
moving the head that is battling with
the queers it must be experiencing
problems with the queers day
mrs. Lapwing the hyenas are gonna come
here they maybe they will also get some
of the benefits because I can see that
there's quite a lot of things falling at
the moment and this hookah Marie nearly
lost that whole carcass from the tree
so I can hear him crashing some bones
there so the piece that he got there it
was big because it was the the neck
bones they just got the neck bones
falling there is what is feeding on at
the moment
they flip so what we are hearing now is
the bones he is crashing those are the
ones that normally develop that kind of
a chalky Carla when the droppings on the
ground for a long time when he's
crushing bones like that is grinding
them for the other animals to come and
eat so now let's go back to Jamie by the
tent who is enjoying the beautiful
sunset
so you can see that he's still very busy
crashing those bones at the moment and
also eating and some of the things that
are coming down there the queers on the
porcupine you can see he did quite a lot
of job already I opted by the tree those
girls am i this porcupine must be old
because the quills are very much low
occupiers can be able to regrow or
regenerate the queers when they lose
them from where they have lost them and
it is a process is something that takes
time and when experiencing the loss of
quills is when they are not safe at all
so during the olden days traditionally
when people were when people are
injected with some of the ingredients
from the trees because we did not have
razors the PACU pants is the one the
quill is the one which used to drill the
little holes here on the skin so that
they can be able to put some of the
traditional ingredients from the plants
the powders in order to strengthen some
of the people from various tribes so
while we are waiting for him to go back
up into the tree let's go back to Jaime
with a beautiful sunset
be pretty I'm hiding behind the grass
yada yada look how tall it is and that
was essentially where we were going with
that scene but unfortunately because you
couldn't hear me probably didn't come
across very well so you get the idea
look it's gorgeous we've been what did I
say again I had it all worked out the
tents been here for a long time but I
don't think we've ever stopped to
appreciate the true beauty of the grass
genre is a cameraman therefore he has an
eye for these things and that was pretty
much all that you missed
oh and that grass can hide all sorts of
things leopards included and myself and
most likely the tick that's probably as
we speak
making its way towards somewhere
unmentionable upon me because now I've
been lying in the grass and it has found
its way now we've sort of been quite
think this through genre it's very
pretty but now I feel compelled to walk
towards you I have to sort of wade
through stands of panicum grass we were
talking about pioneer species panicum of
course I'm not even going to think about
tasting your own panicum because it's
really a very easy grass for you to have
done I said no sorry I have to get past
the tent poles and then I stopped to
pick panicum there we go
so panicum is a type of grass that is
actually nutritionally very valuable but
the previous grasses that I've shown you
and I do believe you haven't got the
third grass yet the previous grasses
that I've shown you are not very good
for eating at all they're pioneer
species that means they need very little
in the way of nutrients but that also
means that they yield very little in the
way of nutrients but that doesn't make
them any less important so they
essentially hold onto the soil let's
skip back to where we were before they
hold onto the soil that hold us in place
when they die their nutrients are fed
back into the soil and gradually over
time the quality of the soil actually
improves which makes way for the next
species of grass to come in which is
known as a sub climax species look
they've changed the names around a
little bit but the process is the same
essentially the pioneer species of grass
stalked the whole process of settling
the soil holding it
place and making the environment
suitable for grasses such as the panicum
grass and in this case that's actually
right at the point it's the type of
grass that grows when the soil is ideal
when the nutrient levels are ideal it's
it's it's a grass that thrives in good
conditions and as a result that makes
panickin very very palatable palatable
panicum it sounds great
which means you can even actually eat
the seeds mmm and they're actually quite
nice it's sort of a bit like tasteless
tasteless some musial granola Jules says
all guessed that the other grass was
spear grass right idea wrong grass very
similar way of spreading its seeds I'm
just checking to see I might even have
some on me now no I don't I haven't
picked up any it's not spear grass I
really look for spear Christ to show you
actually because spear grass is great if
you get it at the right sort of level of
ripeness you can chuck spear grass that
your friend and it will embed itself in
their clothes so spear grass is
fantastic for that but it's not spear
grass come on
somebody must somebody must have covered
I'm sure I've spoken about it on bush
walk before or if I haven't there's got
to be someone who did Steve or James
mm-hmm crystal says thatching grass it
is not thatching grass the yellow
thatching grass is the one latin name of
grass that sticks in my head and I just
remember having to learn it as a mmm as
a guiding student hypothetical eater I
believe no it's not that in grass there
you go that's called showing off mmm and
it's a rule that I have broken because I
can't tell you anything about why it's
called hyper Thea hyper / Celia don't
know mm-hmm I haven't stumped everyone
because I've been checking Twitter and
somebody said the right thing I haven't
stumped everyone I checked Twitter
somebody's got the answer in fact two
people when I last checked I've got the
answer
how can I give you a hint it hmm the
thing is he said I don't think I've seen
knows what the answers are cider Tory
says - dorri says what Tories is the
highest you boys hit something else
because the journeyed panicum till you
get it you're not allowed to link away
from me ah
Jory's is turpentine grass good guess
really good guess and turpentine grass
no turpentine grass of course called
turpentine grass because of the
turpentine like smell it gets convinced
is a liquid wandering around here not to
pin time hmm somebody should have told
FC what it was we could be here for a
while his Asaph through the different
answers Jaya says what grass Panthers
grass I don't know that name hmm I don't
know I I'm not gonna laugh because it
could easily be the name of a grass not
here pampas grass
Oh a pampas grass nope hmm why did Judy
say guys we need out where did Judy say
it was digging awkward
if she's sweating all right I'll tell
you what it is and then FC will tell us
who got it right
it is tassel three on grass so called
because the little bits of the seed or
the little bits of the branch what you
call it why can't I remember the name
spike litt whatever it goes out in three
so it's got a little branch three I
forgot to take it with me so now I can't
show you barb
well done Bob you got it right and I'm
sure do th got it right as well I have
no doubt here we go look here we go now
I've managed to isolate a little bit
yeah Hungary is not wearing shoes
I pulled the third old off so now it's
just a tassel to on it had a third one I
promise but now now it splits away
because it's such a right it's so ripe
now it's so ready for dispersal sorry
hold on look I promise you it's three
it's not tassel two on its tassel three
on and that's on because I know what our
vowels are like a South African that's
on as in aw in own tassel three own yeah
doc there there Jamie not the look there
no no my mother would be terribly
disappointed in me
Bob and Patrick project alpha project
alpha Bob and project alpha and of
course Judy H Judy I knew your name was
in there we're almost going to have to
disqualify Judy from these games I think
definitely disqualified on the basis
that she knows more than we do
and that ladies and gentlemen tassel
three on and that is all I have to tell
you until I return to my tent and writer
the name on it but we're not going to
return to the temp now Chandra is not
wearing shoes and he has to climb back
through the window he says go for it to
eat should we climb back through the
window and into the tent let's do it
okay yeah haha okay no we're not going
to do that in front of you even though
we could do it with great upon we're
instead going to send you back across to
hooker Murray and Sidney himself
we are still here and Haku Mori is now
on the ground trying to finish up
everything that has fallen in Iran
hopefully you'll go up again to the kill
anytime I can see how much is left now
but I can see I can't hear any bones
crashing maybe he's done it might just
wake up at any time and climb but this
marvelous tree to show us more oh I can
yeah it's breaking again I'm gonna bones
day so we can only see just a small
piece but now that the Sun is going down
is the best time for the hyenas to start
moving around chances of the highness to
come and distract him to go up into the
tree they are very much hi SAS as I have
just indicated we are not very far away
from the Jew Mahina den so if any of
those hyenas decides to come here we
might see him going back very quickly to
that tree now there you go so it means
now he's being back again maybe he's
gonna climb the tree again
to go and eat the rest it's always
lovely to see this big cat climbing the
trees so they've got very strong claws
which helps them to grab when they climb
industries instead of going to the
treaty is now living away from the tree
look at that you can see he's got quite
a lot of blood there by the nose and by
the mouth is time maybe to do a little
bit of grooming if not they must have to
then lie down a little bit maybe he's
tired from what he was doing
don't get surprised I am NOT alone and
deciding you will be hearing vehicles as
I'm talking
feeding on a porcupine is a huge
responsibility because every time they
must have to remove the small pieces of
those critters it's not easy
a Vincent what I have seen this I have
witnessed on several occasion is that
highness every time they come to
approach this big cast the because if
they've got something up in a tree they
just go up and be protective high up
there so remember the hyenas sometimes
can be very much aggressive and
potentially dangerous especially if they
have not eat for quite a long time if
they have not eaten for a long time is
when you will see because their level of
aggression is determined by what is in
their stomach when there is nothing at
all in the stomach it's when they get
very much aggressive so if they come
here when they are very hungry you will
see they are going to be able to chase
him up so but he knows very well that
after feeding he must have to clean
himself for a while because it is summer
season there's quite a lot of flies
so now let's leave who koumori and until
we see the next plans let's quickly go
to a tailor who is having some of the
beautiful hippo pajamas we're watching
the ripples of the water because the
hippopotamus idea they are they've come
on No thank goodness because they were
hiding they just got up and down looking
now they're gonna get under the water
again
oh no yes here we go so we here at
Buffalo jam not to look at snorkel Sarah
or scuba Steve I called him Harry Potter
just now but that's not really his name
but we've come here to hopefully hear
the mating call of a leopard well they
don't make mating calls they just make
growly sounds at one another but we
haven't heard anything just yet I'm not
gonna go on foot to try and find these
there best version because it's probably
not a wise thing to do they're gonna be
very unhappy with me but also I'm mostly
gonna chase scaly cats in Ghana who's
terrified of people on foot and then
well I can't imagine the labor day said
he's mating with would be very relaxed
on foot if she can't even stand the
sight of a car so we're not going to
disturb him it's the last thing we
wanted to do so we're just sort of
enjoying a moment and the sounds of the
turtle dad's I suppose that you can
probably hear it was a pair of them
calling
there's three turtle that's now calling
at the same time hoping that we'd arrive
and at least in Ghana would be out
having a drink of water
but he's not care I could also move
further up the drainage line that's a
possibility
what's on earth what's on snow cool
series I can you see that white things
in zone but we can't zu can we zoom in
anymore
oh no come back up she's much smaller
and then Scuba Steve on the left it's
not a white patch on her eye at first I
thought it was a tick but it's obviously
not a tick I don't know listen listen
the lipids are meeting
enjoy the ambience right up
it's so hard to see them because they'd
literally they're like they're like
right down here aren't they they but I
don't think we're gonna be able to get
to the mistress and zone that is cool
okay so they're still yeah I didn't
think they were gonna go fast look
they'd maybe move further in a drainage
line I'm just gonna have to do this
sneaky thing try and go down a level but
I don't know how they're gonna react to
that but we'll give it a bash I mean
ideally I'd like to go they're gonna try
the rosemary years so they could all one
to let more leopard coats that would be
ideal
I'm not sure I don't wanna get close to
him and she's trying to find a vantage
point no we're not gonna see you nothing
the other thing that I'm terrified of is
that the grass so long he's done kick
out a full before like she I'm
looking for a conch corner iskut cuz
that's definitely gonna scare the
Nathans how does it look they sent a
fine
you see if a card look in from the side
they're just struggling to find a gap we
were very rugged very quietly do you
think
it's very close here so they're in here
somewhere but can you see them can you
see them so as you can see them yeah but
the more they gonna run away I can't we
can't trust answers as you can see them
so let's try he wants me to poke my nose
and I see senseless standing up now so
he can see a little bit it's just a
sticky on I don't want to crunch it I'm
gonna crunch it that's a
well if you're wondering why I'm going
so slowly it's because I know we have a
great good it's all one road over there
in the grass we're not really gonna be
able to see them so yeah also they'll
probably only mate again in the next 15
to 20 minutes so one raw I think I can
hear one walking but yes it is we're
gonna are there one just flicked its
tail they're walking No
since all we have to convert to move
we have been defeated by water pits
today they are moving off into the drain
implant and go back my thing is that
they weren't terrified they didn't run
all right this is also gonna be fun
because I can see since I just told me
if I'm gonna go off the edge on your
side I'll watch myself yeah yep
hmm I don't think we're gonna get a view
of these cats I'm afraid now V well
she's very very nervous
she just needs him into the thickest a
very very thick vegetation I can't I
think I'll just leave them in peace
that's fine they don't want to be seen
they don't have to be seen off you guys
Jamie she's obviously not left the tent
she hasn't decided to go on a night walk
let's go see if she's still talking
about grass well Taylor you kept me on
the edge of my seat certainly watching
Taylor trying to creep up and see if she
could spot the mating leopards I could
hear them we were listening with her we
could even hear the other person that
was on the vehicle with her scoot out of
the way as the cameras swung across so
we could hear all the sounds giving you
all the insights into the behind the
scene things well I bet some of you
noticed on to your next grass I know
that this has just been the most
enthralling tense segment that you've
ever done Chandra's not anything he's
he's been enthralled but to be honest
I'm not sure all we have left to discuss
in this tent I really feel as though
there we have covered many many a topic
in here so I thought we'd try something
different all right have a look at this
one under the microscope tell us what
you think
which grass is this I shouldn't have
left the tape there even got the brand
of it better hide that away so below us
over there is a type of grass it too is
a pioneer species because of course
these were all collected outside the
tent so most of them are pioneer species
although of course we've got some
panicum as well would you like to see
the microscope no maybe perhaps no no
I'm guessing that's not
microscope it's a keyword I would like
to show them the small flower there we
go
[Laughter]
I'm only playing Nina don't stress there
we go we've got some flowers to show you
the tiny little flowers so of course
these seeds are still being well not the
seeds themselves but at least plants
still be effective iced tea Andre what
did you do you read it you knocked it
out of focus there okay that's right
it's sort of oh dear now I've knocked it
out of focus okay Andre and I don't on
allowed to work together on this oh well
I mean this you want to learn more about
grasses Andre things blowing there's a
breeze blowing through the tent lots of
evidence of pollen as well pee heart
would like to know if it is a member of
or not member sorry if it is the
Sawtooth love grass it isn't and you
know that the Sawtooth love grass after
being probably one of the most common
grass species that we see out here was
one that I could not find around the
tent so no it is not it's not a narrow
gross stuff species and it is another
grass species whose a Latin name is a
forever embedded in my mind but it is
not saw truth
saw tooth love grass the fine thing
about sawtooth love grass is we have a
deep-fryer potential with that name saw
as in saw as in the saw that you use to
cut wood not saws and it's uncomfortable
joy wants to know if it's cross grass I
don't know if my hearing is completely
off today it's possible cross grass
cross grass yes joy Joyce's cross grass
not cross grass although I can sort of
see where you get that thought from in
terms of the shape of where the various
things that I can't remember the name
for what are they called are they called
well I have to look it up I mean I
didn't know what they were called I can
see what you mean in the layout of the
inflorescence let's just go with that a
sort of cross structure African fly and
Bob's want to know if it's herringbone
marvelous spot-on
you are correct I can't remember who
guessed herringbone earlier for one of
the other grasses but this is in fact
herringbone so named because at a
distance you don't really see the
structure of the inflorescence so it
sort of looks a little bit like a piece
of it was African fly there you go
African fly it's all yours
herringbone grass and and it just looks
a little bit like it's been full pulled
out of a fish skeleton or something like
that apparently look I mean the people
who name grass are about as committed to
it as they're the people who name plants
like white berry bushes and what other
created names do we get there's a few
bird names as well that are truly
inspired right so now what we're going
to do is add the herringbone onto our
grade three school project so while I do
that I hope that you all stayed awake
and learnt lots about grasses
enthralling as it has been a hawk amore
on the other hand cannot possibly stay
awake
not much is happening at the moment here
where I am you can see who is now
resting again I think the little bit of
food we had earlier on the ground is
enough for him for now as it's not
showing any sign of climbing back into
the tree as I indicated if maybe the
hyena comes here is when he will be
forced to go up into the tree
so you can see it's not even worried at
all he's his caucus is koumori is one of
those animals which are not that very
old he might be now I'm not too sure of
his exact age but already I know that
already he started Demick ating his
territory
so when democratic the territory that
normally happens when the animal is more
than four years before that yes they can
demarcate but to defend it like now
there is an issue that aku mori is
having some cubs with a cassava and that
is a sign that Okamura is a much wad and
is a protective adult
oh my apologies not with kochava with
shedule ooh shedule is one of those
females which has been spotted in the
area having some cups not very long time
ago so it is suspected that the cups are
for oak amore
so if you look at his facial expression
you can see who Coomer looks very much
aggressive I have seen him on a fight
before with when he was chasing when he
was chasing over sauna on a fight
somewhere around this area I saw that he
can be very much aggressive this area
where we are is way is roaming around a
lot so you know matter comes here and go
around the quarantine area and come back
Christine yeah indeed Akuma is having an
after-dinner nap at the moment but we
were very much interested to hear to see
him high up by that tree trying to take
off those quills I wanted to see how is
he going to take off the quills from
that porcupine he did not show us much
about that
according to the Honorable James Richard
who is always accurate when it comes to
the identification and the age of these
cards
Okumura was born somewhere around 2013
and thank you very much James Richard
for that kind of a clarification
I'm close to come moment as no money by
this time of the net is well we are
hearing is starting to make calls
so you can see that this cat is just
lying down here and there is no
destructions but by this time of the
night normally is when we are hearing
the calls from the hyenas a lot it has
been very quiet
I wonder where these hyenas are today oh
here is the hyena it's not calling when
talking about them here at the back they
oh I just put it to hide and apologies
for that pole we have just spotted the
hyena is somewhere coming now I can see
that hi nice loli approaching so let's
see what is going to happen listen to
the bob loss so the hyena is approaching
a hawk oomori at the moment
Okamoto picked up the noise from the
hyena approaching you can see the iana
is being warned and this Rana is now
moving away I can see the High Knights
moving away their apologies for the pole
the hyena approached us from the bed
so the hyena decided to leave home or
maybe the hyenas gonna come back or the
other clan members might come because
some of them can be very much aggressive
when they are in a group
so normally the hyenas when they are
wanted by these predators they don't
really go far you might find that the
hyena which has been won't just now it's
just gonna find a place and hide little
bit and come back and try the lock again
while we are waiting to see if the Hina
is gonna come back or not let's go back
to Taylor
we've moved on from the Leopards just
because we couldn't get a view of them
and I really don't want to disturb them
I tried my best but like that was I
pushed it and I'm not gonna push it
anymore no I wonder if it's too early to
see a bar now I might go and try and
find the ones that we've seen at the dam
cam we will give it a bash also Janie
said earlier there were baboons alarming
so we might go and scratch around there
with our spotlight we should actually
get there just in the nick of time for
darkness and then the other thing isn't
on the topic of the barn owls a lot of
you're asking I've seen on Twitter about
going to the old barn owl nest way they
used to sort of stay where we had the
chicks expert web but we can't go there
anymore because it's Andrew it's in a
construction site that the that nest is
fine but we can't get in the way we used
to also its but it's in invasion of
privacy but I got a serious level so
we're gonna say goodbye to that nest and
us going there unfortunately so that is
why I haven't gone past to kind of check
because I can't get in there now because
there's a house so they might be able to
see them so we'll just have to try and
find another nest somewhere that's all
we'll have to do which is I suppose not
really easy otherwise we'd be seeing
them all the time but we'll try and find
some chameleons maybe we'll bump into
another predator who knows I would like
to see dot dot dot finish the sentence
Enzo what do you want to see
I'm gonna start making up answers for
you if you take so long to answer like
Craig's your first thinking okay
everybody must think about it tell me
what you want to see you tonight
probably won't be able to show it to you
though huh Anisha ask to see a plant
maybe left us Jamie Jamie so good she's
in the change she's doing the grasses
she's gonna make it easy a little
flowchart with diagrams and things and
fun facts about grasses that'll be nice
Jamie I hope you have highlighters and
crayons and thing I suppose you wouldn't
have crayons but maybe a nice colored
pen definitely need highlighters or an
any tub diagram a flow chart or
presentation who would like to see a
cheetah
sorry I don't you just see the fur the
name once in the beginning but a cut off
so I heard row row row your boat you're
lucky you didn't say row three times a
minha otherwise it would have sang that
song so row you want you and cheetah
this area hmm now I think we've probably
got a better chance of finding a leopard
to be honest so oh there ends emeriti
fighbird and so no I don't know if we'll
find a cheetah it's so secure ah there
we go
rosemarie very easy to please as Evie
said any owl is a good owl that's fine
we can try and we'll try and do that I
just haven't even seen any pull spotted
owl it's a barred owl that's at all but
with all the foliage on the trees if you
make it quite difficult to spot them
princess Kimberly you want to see how
yena cuts okay maybe it depends how much
time we have after we check damn we do
you know what we did this afternoon that
was actually so much fun is that so what
we did is we drove from chadwin from jay
sebring pan and from jay sebring pan we
basically switched the car off and we
win Oh
racing in neutral though so we only had
the speed that we were going weren't
going very fast but we gained momentum
and we went through the malai Twp it was
like a roller coaster but like
freewheeling it was so cool it was so
fast it was obviously it's crazy we made
it all the way through and out all the
way to the top of trend and actually
that's what I see is that if we had our
own natural momentum would we be able to
make it through and we did make it
through it was quite cool did you enjoy
that so far that's been the highlight of
my Drive it's going through that dip
it's made me want to go to a theme park
which I will have to do when I go back
to Johannesburg I need to go to gold
reef city and ride all the roller
coasters
and play games oh and love playing games
so many lover arcade okay will we keep
searching for our own predators the side
on Central Road heading towards a dance
they'll see me on the camp
damn cam in a minute off you go Sydney's
still sitting with nakamori and
hopefully he'll wake up and devour his
prickly meal you can see that now a Hoku
mori is very pretty much relaxed and
guess what they are two hyenas at the
moment here we are and one of the
Highness is just crashing the bones
somewhere not very far away from where
we are from the bones and the meat that
fell from there from the tree hyena
managed to pick up something you can
hear at the crunching of bones
so maybe this is going to gang up so
early
the is not so good morning the first
Heine went to koumori and was warned as
Kimura just showed up the teeth and
their eye energy aspect off the second
one came and he did the same but the
second one was too clever because he
then walked around and approached the
tree where this food was falling you can
hear his breaking the bone somewhere not
far away from where I am
so one of the hyenas has been very lucky
so you can see that a large platform
that meet who has fallen here because he
couldn't manage to eat everything when
he was on the ground but here we am
highlights eating in his just managed to
get something where this big cat was and
he's not worried is not even going up
into the tree and he is just lying down
here very much next he knows that his
caucus is very much safe
he is not even worried about the hyenas
which is eating not very far away from
him now he's looking at the other eye
you know which is now moving away
the porcupine has got a lot of meat so
if you can check the cat we are talking
about here is Hawk amore
Okumura alone a porcupine is way much
bigger if we look at that porcupine
there you can see there is quite a lot
of meat available on that porcupine so
but if you can check the cats such as
the leopard who Komori they can even go
after a mongoose which is very much
small so I think here the efforts versus
the energy Okumura is going to get after
feeding is balanced
[Music]
he doesn't want to show us the coupon he
doesn't want to either caught the
porcupine which is very difficult to eat
but he doesn't want to go up there I can
see he stops interested he's just want
to sleep I'm not even too sure if he has
been to the waterhole
earlier but the stomach is not telling
me that he has been to the hotel so now
I can see that is getting dark here
where I am and I've got to give you the
best sightings through the infrared so
that we can see these animals nicely and
without disturbing them I am NOT going
to use the artificial light at all
you can see how beautiful that animal is
like when is by the infrared
he's just concentrating on some of the
birds who are now trying to make noise
try this time of the night is when a lot
of birds
advertising themselves in their
territory the bed's can be also be very
much territorial so the infrared it is a
kind of a coming away by we can be able
to see these animals without disturbing
them the animals are in a complete
darkness but when you look at the animal
from the scream as if is during the
daylight but you will only see it on
black and white so here where we are we
are managing a natural system and we
don't want to interfere on this natural
environment because when shining the
artificial lights sometimes we can make
the predator visible by the prey and we
can also make the prey animals visible
by the Predators
I can see that cumin is now getting
jealous because that Hina got back again
to where he was dropping the meat and
he's now showing some interest so let's
go back to the tent
so why local more Easter's I'm ready to
put you to sleep once again that sounds
terrible I made make you go to sleep it
was a horrible way of phrasing it so you
know what's really sad is that in the
entire duration of the son said safari
we've done four crosses so quickly we'll
do two more we'll do two more cuz I
reckon it'll look nice on my grade 3
project quickly microscope and go
quickly see if you can guess what that
is I will show you it in a second in
real life and then to turn ok there's
some seeds in there there's some flowers
all there's even a little thingy
wandering around on there I don't know
what it is but it is very present ok I'm
going to take it out and here we go I'm
grabbing it now and it is now out from
under the microscope and look there
quickly you can get that one easily if
see you don't know what it is do you
I forgot to warn you he but you can get
that one quickly I'm pretty sure you all
know what it is we often complain when
the vehicles don't have it let's put it
that way
and vehicles don't have it when they go
into the drainage line around Gary cut
line and behind both of dam and up
towards Sydney's Dam ok apparently the
YouTube is delayed next one while while
the youtubers figure it out they're a
bit behind the times and next one and go
the feed is delayed in general ok quick
think Kathy says it is wheat it is not
wheat it is something different entirely
Chris service is that it is finger grass
it's not although finger grass was one
of the grasses I picked up but it's not
the one I was demonstrating
apparently one of you says it's riot and
even here it was post Friday it is not
rye it is princess Kimberly senses
buffers of grass Noda I think I think
we've had a slight misunderstanding
there we don't have brothels hook
because it happens we cannot drive there
but we can drive two buffers look damn
alright next Ross go this is getting
confusing oh there's something in it
it's moving around it's moving look at
it are you probably haven't port wrapped
my pony be miss desperately trying to
get back to its home in the rise are
well done it is indeed signal grass not
this grass the one we were looking at
before we now have a lot of ground to
cover because Nina tells me this is
probably my last segment so you know
hold on to your hats folks it's gonna be
quick
I'm sure that's him a party B let me
take him out quickly kept taking the
grass out right well done signal grass
indeed somewhere in here there is a port
raft B where is it there it is oh it's
not a B what is that it's a spider a
little spider sorry
yeah you are oops sorry here's a little
spider little spider gone no little
spiders back surprise okay this is an
easy grass very easy grass we often talk
about its virtues when surprised but he
says guinea grass it is enough to guinea
grass I do you feel a little bit oh
sorry Chandra I do feel a little bit
sort of like it's a fan calyx it is not
red oat grass the the waving fields of
red oak grasses mr. Henry would say also
known as red grass Sumida try Andrew
it's not red grass lettuce it's
something unintelligible I imagine that
Lenin Willard the type said it wasn't
unintelligible that needeth
strip stir I was confused tell me what
you say I'm so sorry I promise you I'm
just
any ideas yonder sorry Mina I promise
yes gdh has got it hmm is Feathertop
quorus grass there we go okay quickly
before her camera gets up and starts
wandering off for something and we have
to link away and you never see us again
oh Linda was referring to a bug the bug
that we were looking at that was a that
was a little spider who's now on the
desk and unfortunately cannot have
enough air the top Cloris anymore
because it's going on my art project I
would give myself a c-plus for this it's
not very good at all
Bush felt signal and
but Andy says it looks like we're the
top allergy gracias exactly cold for
Taurus just don't look too closely at
that I don't know how to spell Cloris
[Laughter]
I think it's ch and there you go my art
for my art project
the grasses that we manage to collect
and you manage to identify over the
course of one sunset Safari well done
everyone
very impressive one two three four five
six only a good couple of hundred to go
folks those are the major ones that we
found around the tent finger grass
didn't even get a show in yeah all right
I'm going to forgot there was stuff on
the back of this I'm going to leave this
here for some poor hapless guide to find
when they decide to present next
meanwhile while we we leave them with
that mess let's go across to hook Maury
who didn't leave the hyenas much of a
mess at all
[Music]
Maurice till now in bed you can see and
if you don't look carefully I'm telling
you it's not easy to see him from the
naked eyes you can see it nicely because
it's through the infrared but here I am
I can promise you is very easy to pass
this animal so the prey animals can even
easily approach Yoko mori at the moment
so you can hear the nightjars are also
up now I can hear one of them is making
some call not very far away here so that
is telling us that now is the beginning
of the nocturnal life is when we are
expecting Okumura to wake up and climb
the tree
so you can see that the stomach has got
something now he ate a little bit day on
the ground you can see that the stomach
is showing some developments there when
we got EI was not like this so those are
the beautiful spare the beautiful spots
which have this animals to blend with
the surrounding I didn't copy the a
question from I D a very nicely if you
can repeat that
they are eveness I don't think they will
be able to eat the pills I saw here that
China was not eating the quills was just
eating only at the meat because he
dropped the neck and that neck was still
having the head and that is why there
was some lot of meat that's why the
stomach is looking beef so they query
from these polka Pines hyenas must be
knowing them very well some people they
even think they poco pineapples are
poisonous but they are not really
poisonous these just that they can be
very much painful so you can see those
will stay
this is a very pretty account
indeed you can see that now is streaming
so look at that so it means there must
be something coming I saw how he reacted
because normally this animals can be
able to hear from far row when we got
here earlier the breathing rate on this
cat it was not fast as we are seeing it
was very nice relaxed because the
stomach are still very much empty but
maybe now because quite a lot of pockets
and the space has been occupied by what
he has just eaten a liya on that is why
now is breathing just like this
so I can't see what he's looking at but
I can promise you is looking at
something maybe is the I inna because
that is where the other hyena got
disappeared it is very much away for a
catch to spend such a lot of time on the
ground when having something up in a
tree cat
the possibilities of him to take another
kill they are very high I'm going to
take you back to what I have witnessed
here in Duma whereby asana was catching
some of the prey animals and hide them
by one of the jackal berries at one
stage or Sodom managed to have two
different kills and they were all hosted
by the different trees he had a small
Nala and he had an Impala so you can see
the animals they are so very much
opportunistic and they will take action
every time a pretty animal present
itself the fact that the animals got
killed already doesn't matter he will go
after something which is passing by so
the possibilities of the pet who Komori
to kick something if there is any any
presence of a prey animal here they are
very much hi so now let's go back to
Taylor who is searching for something
during the dark
hi everybody if he missed me probably
not right we are driving on sandy patch
now I did just quickly check towards
Sydney's dam just to see if the Inca
humans maybe came this way so what's
nice Dillon earlier today he's heard
anything else on the lens and he says no
this is just a top 5 Torchwood females
that have been spotted at in coral that
I was telling you about
I think this morning I was telling you
about them so they haven't actually seen
in coomer's oh and then he mentioned
about the kuma mail and the Hmong again
boys will the two of them that were
together but they obviously crossed into
Jumman still didn't see where they
crossed out
strange very very very strange so I
thought we might as well just come in
check this area once more because me
they'll jump out or they'll be sitting
on the road this seems like sandy patch
at the moment sandy patch and we're tell
accesses like they go to route so we
will check they go to route and also
it's a llama the princess didn't pop out
either braixen had heard that's no I
didn't hear that he heard could you
alarming and in Pilar alarming and he
said well ages are on two and dance
hoping that she was going to pop out but
it didn't sound like she did so she's
sneaky cat but maybe she'll be there in
the mornin whose lots of food around for
her but a bit big water back really big
and parlour arms I don't know if she's
strong enough to take down and a Potter
I'm just you know she has the experience
I mean definitely thinks she can take
down a young part lamb no problem
described here day Kirsty and book
she'll be fine but not not a big impart
around that yeah that's gonna be a bit
of a a bit of a challenge
she doesn't really have much weight to
sort of throw around like not liked um
burden can I tell you about the cool
thing that I saw maybe some of you read
the blog that I wrote I'll tell you now
Firefly I yes I think if tiny until
amber had a meeting I don't think it's
gonna be a particularly nice one she
won't even look at a night job who wants
to see a night job and I think there'll
be some snarling no you can't see the
night job because it's not thrown away
obviously I don't know why I even
stopped and so Tong he's not gonna be
impressed
so I'm probably trying you know say hey
mom what's up but I think I think tiny
he's tired now she's she was wanting to
well she's given up babysitting duty
she's like right be free you're on your
own
she'll tolerate a light I mean we've
seen it when dad a bush baby you saw
that Senzo what are they my eyes up top
there on the tree sorry stand by
everyone
oh that's not oh where did they go can
you zoom into that yeah that there I
think it might have been a birdie it was
some serious eye shine going on oh no no
no no sense of anything
bottom push baby yes everybody there is
Alyssa Gallagher how cool is that you
can just see it it's a bit difficult
wind infrared now we've gotten into
infrared everybody I'm so gonna shine my
light that's so cool with bouncing down
to the bottom branches now are you going
they'll be very happy at this time of
the year too with all the bugs that are
about we that's so finger still bouncing
I think we're gonna lose it though
because you've now got too many trees in
front of us but that was a fantastic
sighting that was something I completely
forgot about that lived in this area
Bush babies I also wonder how Lauren is
enjoying the sound of the hyraxes in the
Mara I'd love to hear a feedback when
when the Mar is back up and running
again so are we having some technical
difficulties down there with the
interwebs and when they back up and
running though we must happen we'll have
to ask Lauren what she thinks about that
right whoa I caught a locust look but
it's sitting in a very inappropriate
place so I have to catch it first I'm
doing an infrared how cool is this like
a rain locust or something
it's very camouflage cutters all browns
and grays I've got big eyes
it's antennae look like grass don't you
think it's pretty cool
look at all the sort of serrated bits on
the back of its legs and so that's quite
cool you can see quite an eye see look
at that
and what's a great defense mechanism to
have that and did see its wings are
folded back awesome
that's what jumped on me though see I
didn't even get a fright this time lots
of little nocturnal critters okay but
we'll keep driving we'll let this little
creature live here until it decides to
fly away I hope you won't fly away back
in my face I will not be very happy with
that
I will flick you if you do that Joker
you'll get flicked off far away
nice bush baby locust grass up a thing
what else are you gonna see next let's
go with puff adder I would light snow
scrubby scrubby off the road
please will you vacate to the left no
thank you
let's gone back for a second wouldn't
know this is a fun game that we play
with the scrub his chased the scrub here
around an evening that's going on there
just keep searching
okay maybe Jamie will be able to tell us
exactly what kind of creature this was
sitting here Jamie it's brown and it had
a bit of gray on it it's a good luck
let's go back to Jamie and attend to
might even tell you about some night
grasses that's what it looks like when
someone throws you under the bus whew
straight under the wheels I am I have
absolutely no idea what locust there was
I wasn't even looking I'm sorry I didn't
even I was not even watching interesting
thing about swarms of locusts on a
totally different topic - grass thank
goodness
although I suppose relevant to grass in
its own way there's a whole interesting
thing that I read the other day about
the swarms of locusts that occur in
certain areas and for a long time
biologists were totally baffled because
these locusts had a specific colouring
to them and they looked very different
to the seasonal locusts that they would
see every year and they couldn't
understand where this different species
was coming from they're just all of a
sudden happened to come up in these
swarms and I you know what the cross
pollen is all gotta buzz cuz well I
cannot stop sneezing I'm gonna do our
best to try it all back for the segment
anyway what they eventually discovered
is that locusts went on their own a lot
of species of locusts have a very
particular color scheme and they
actually avoid each other but in a
situation where it starts to favor high
populations of that particular locust
they actually become a totally different
color and often become a bit larger and
a bit more elongated and a little bit
stronger and then all of a sudden that
population booms they start to move
together when they start to change color
like that and all of a sudden you've got
a swarm fascinating fact and it's purely
to distract you from the fact that I've
got absolutely no idea which locust was
sitting on a Taylor's dashboard last
thing about grass because I've now
burned through all the content that we
had and all content that I collected I
have to show you something funny
different grasses have different grazing
values as discussed
pannikin grass fed
tastic for cows something like I'll put
it up for you too sick there's Andre and
then you've got something like the
carrot seed for example or the tassel 3
on which doesn't have very good grazing
value at all
so reference books about grass will
actually specifically have little
symbols for it and I just love the key
that they've chosen in this grass book
which definitely if you were to ask me
isn't my a gentleman called oats or if
you are interested in grass so this is a
this is a happy cow for for when it's
high grazing value and then this is this
is a sort of semi sort of sad cow
because the sonne average grazing value
and in my absolute favorite is this is
this is a low low grazing value grass
which is a very angry cow so don't feed
your cows um carrot seed grass or
herringbone or anything like that or
you'll have a very angry cow I mean it
works it works very well a suitable way
of expressing how cars feel about those
type of grasses and I imagine if you
were to replace that car symbol with say
a rhino you could have an angry Rhino
when presented with something like
carrot seed or perhaps you could have a
really happy Rider when presented with
red grass little happy Rhino symbol
there probably should have used well
grasses are relevant to people other
than us farmers of course find the very
very important to chat about I've run
out of things to tell you about grass
the end goodbye it's been an absolute
joy I hope you didn't get too
overexcited and just when you think the
excitement is just just too much huh
Komori is going to add to it by doing a
marvelous job of being fast asleep
Okumura still lying down here and not
showing any sign of doing anything I can
see that the chances for us to see him
climbing back into that tree they are
very much slim so I think I've also got
to leave him and see if maybe we can
find something as I hear the hyenas not
very far here they were making some
noise I don't know if maybe there is
something happening there because here
it looks like is going to be quiet for
quite a while
I can hear their anus are starting to
call a lot and a lot of them are not far
away from here where I am so you can see
that now Hoku mori is enjoying his deep
sleep I'm left with no option but to
leave him and see if we can find
something interesting maybe we might be
lucky and find something here by the
treehouse damn
so the hyenas were just making noise not
very far away from here
and I just want to try my luck there may
be some other competitors are coming
this side
yeah the hyena City we making noise not
very far away from here much more
towards the treehouse Dam which is where
I'm going to try my luck now
the bush is very thick the bush is very
much big here where I am it's difficult
to see far
so I'm gonna have to look nicely for the
road here it's not easy but I managed to
see where the road is so now let's go
back to Taylor
hello again we're chasing scrub is still
we're gonna go find a white tailed
Mongoose now don't you come back out get
off the road
okay I'm just focusing I'm not driving
over the scrubby knew you had an
opportunity you've had ample
opportunities move
don't turn right don't turn right we're
going right don't go right yeah blocked
it off managed to evade the scrub here
let us go and find a white tailed
Mongoose with the last few minutes
oh there's lightning no we're gonna
watch the lightning yay entertainment
since well maybe this is where it's all
gonna happen now we're gonna have
another pair of mating letters the
lightning in the background in a tree
you're a mate in a tree like they're
doing India I've never seen leopards the
sad
who I don't know who asked that sorry
Nina I didn't get the name again
the way there's a long delay it's always
awkward Pickwick okay cancel nevermind
don't know what to watch a lot ding
Tommy thank you use it it's a rain Lucas
I've got something right for a change
yeah whoa watch someone else is gonna
where is dr. Owen he's gonna go no it's
not it's this one I'm Johnny joking I
really do if it's if I'm wrong I think
I'm probably wrong just trying to figure
out where I can get a view because I
can't remember what they really looked
like but I thought that they looked like
this this one doesn't enjoy my driving
like a late as such yeah oh hang on
we've got a little gap ski can we get a
gap ski here
I don't know if we're gonna see the
lightning now but oh there was some day
but I think it was better there that
cloud you see their sins oh I'll show
you now yeah that part that my life
doesn't make if you keep going a bit
more yeah yeah so that ain't part of the
cloud that you can see just to the right
of the marula tree let's see if that
lights up yes so some under the marula
tree there's no thunder those who and I
were able to listen to anything for the
crickets if you like
oh did you get that sense
[Music]
I think it was something I'm just
drinking it was me everybody was me
making noises
that's amazing angel I'm so glad that
there's an elephant of the Damned come
enjoy you can always switch over and
watch it there we're not going to head
down that way unfortunately I'm not
gonna bother the innocent at night you
know but in furry I just think it's
unnecessary if we bump them cool but I'm
gonna go searching for a elephant at
nighttime what else we got share scenes
or lightning is not happening this
evening so I'm searching the trees
around us for content nothing fine
it's gone you can be free okay the
locust does now I left the building or
left the vehicle and it will get some
more bush babies it's become quite an
overgrown area I'm surprised since 2016
how quarantine has transformed it was a
lot more open a couple of years ago and
now all the silver class studies have
come through and lots of new bush
willows and they're starting to encroach
this fairly open area and if it carries
on I reckon like another five or six
years it's not going to be open at all I
think it would just be littered with all
these encroaching trees that's the
problem that is the problem then we
won't see any zebra ever again no just
joking we see them on other pots too but
I'm gonna turn around yeah because it's
almost the end of Safari
okay these marula trees are good for
bush babies because I've seen them in
here before lots of them but probably
not tonight because I think we already
got spoiled with one bush baby we okay
we're gonna turn around no fights held
Mongoose just yet so lots of bugs as I
drove into the grass chase them all away
luckily I didn't your mom's today who
live in Seoul okay come on last-minute
white tailed Mongoose or honey badger
one of the two it would be great
will we see it I don't know about thirty
seconds everybody thirty Seconds our
sensors got the moon as we're driving
sorry everyone
we're cruising that's really nice
beautiful lovely moon but should still
be able to see the stars isn't that
gorgeous
right but that's all the time we have
with you this evening so thank you very
much for joining us and we look forward
to doing it all again tomorrow morning
good night bye bye
[Music]